il y est combrée en eure et loir
bonjour bienvenue à la maison de tante
léonie musée marcel proust maison de son
oncle et de sa tante paternelle
c'est là que le futur écrivain marcel
proust venait passer ses vacances
pendant son enfance la maison et a
besoin vraiment d'être plus que
rafraîchi il a besoin d'être restaurée
donc c'est un site auquel on tient
beaucoup surtout quand en 2022
c'est le centenaire de la mort de marcel
proust pièces emblématiques de la
demeure cette chambre où marcel proust
dormait autrefois fissures tapisserie
défraîchi infiltration ou encore
humidité ici une rénovation de la pièce
est clairement nécessaire tout tout
ondes un petit peu tout s'abîme avec le
temps a bien sûr juste en face sans
doute la chambre d'elisabeth la tante du
jeune marcel proust
c'est ici que tante léonie son
personnage de roman lui offre une petite
madeleine devenu célèbre
cette fameuse madeleine qui ne va
tromper dans son thé et d'un seul coup
il va se retrouver avec de bonnes
sensations et à ce moment là donc ils se
rappellent enfin ces fameuses vacances
qu'ils passaient donc à combret quand il
était petit ces moments merveilleux
parce qu'il adorait venir ici dans cette
pièce est chargé de souvenirs
la tapisserie a également besoin d'un
sérieux coup de neuf donc ici notre
endroit mais ici également et dans toute
la maison
la liste des travaux à effectuer longue
rénover des façades seront sur jardin de
restaurer les lambris et les appuis de
fenêtres d'assurer la mise en
accessibilité pour les personnes à
m'ôter un mobilité réduite pardon avec
un ascenseur au 6 rue de dr prusse de
mettre aux normes l'électricité le
chauffage
et puis donc de restaurer les sols
notamment au premier étage les pavés
sont sont très abîmées son jardin fleuri
sa cuisine pittoresque son salon
oriental et sa façade en mosaïque connu
dans le monde entier
cette maison rassemble tous les
souvenirs liés à l'écrivain un vaste
chantier de restauration va donc
s'ouvrir pour la sauver du péril tout en
conservant son authenticité
depuis la création du loto du patrimoine
260 monuments ont été sauvés en france